[Music]
let's start with the Google cloud
migration journey we have been showing
this to customers for a very long time
and as more and more customers migrate
their workloads to Google cloud we've
been able to validate this over and over
and over again and the key thing to this
the reason we keep talking about that is
because it works it takes an inherently
complex and monstrous process of a cloud
migration and puts it down into very
manageable and executable chunks of work
now we know that this has to happen in
specific order we discover and assess
our application landscape we build the
foundation of GCP services from iam and
networking and basic architecture then
we actually perform the migration itself
and once that migration is done you
assess all of the things that you
assumed in the process and you go ahead
and start optimizing for cost or
performance or capability or whatever
your application needs and then it's
also important to remember that there
are multiple ways that we can get there
you can do a traditional lift and shift
where you just want to lower the overall
complexity and increase the speed of
moving services to the cloud you can do
the improve and move where you want to
refactor some local code in order to
take advantage of cloud native tools
before you actually migrate the services
up or you can do rip and replace where
you just want to start over with the
full toolkit of cloud at your fingertips
but the key thing to this and as anyone
in the room who's ever done a cloud
migration can tell you is we all hear
that story of no - cloud migrations are
ever the same and I'm going to clarify
that statement for the room is it's a
personal stand I want to take here which
is that all successful cloud migrations
are unique in their own way because you
all have different technologies and
industry verticals and data centers and
all of these things but all failed cloud
migrations all fail for the exact same
reason they either didn't have a plan to
begin with or they didn't stick to the
plan that they built on and we know that
these things are incredibly easy to talk
about an incredibly hard to actually
execute and when we see a customer that
comes through follows this journey makes
a plan it has a passion for learning
exploring and testing
see success and today is the story of
one such customer in Kroger digital I'd
like to introduce Joe Timmins a
Technical Account Manager here at Google
to begin the rest of the story awesome
Thank You Kyle so I am in the Google
cloud professional services organization
and for the last year and a half I've
had the privilege of working with Kroger
in Cincinnati on their migration journey
and I just wanted to talk a little bit
about that today
but before I dive into that I want to
talk more broadly about why retailers
love google cloud so in order to think
about where we're going in retail but
let's first take a minute and look
backwards I'm kind of bitter because I
missed the cool attribute of being a
millennial by two years so I was born
two years too early to be called a
millennial but growing up in the 80s and
90s in terms of retail all you had was a
retail brick-and-mortar store or a
catalog that was pretty much it and
malls were the thing everybody went to
the mall and everybody loved them all
and my priority at that time was buying
apparel so when I went to the mall I
would go in and buy the latest and
greatest and the coolest shirts let's
think about that experience and has that
experience changed that much from 25
years ago to today if we were to walk in
to those same brands that I bought from
before not that much however the next 25
years are going to be incredible for the
brick-and-mortar store I believe it will
be a Renaissance because of a confluence
of incredible technologies that are all
coming together at the right time to do
that technologies like computer vision
IOT edge compute machine learning and
obviously the public cloud using all of
these technologies together the customer
experience will be totally transformed
not only digitally but also in the store
and that's what we hear from a lot of
our retailers that I talk to is that
that on the channel seamless experience
is their priority Warren Buffett has a
famous quote he says the most important
decision that you'll make in your life
is who you marry and we believe a Google
cloud the most important decision that
you will make or your cio will make is
which cloud they choose to innovate with
so let's talk about Kroger
136 year-old company started in
Cincinnati and they have over 2,800
retail stores multiple brands they do
have a five billion dollar digital run
rate and they're growing like
gangbusters online at a 58% growth last
quarter 60 million families rely on
Kroger annually to serve them for their
groceries as well as 14 million shoppers
pass through their doors every day and
Kroger has this amazing purpose that
they have stated that they want to feed
the human spirit and they're also going
through a huge digital transformation
and they call that digital
transformation restocked Kroger and
we've been proud to be a big part of
that strategy over the last year and a
half so what were Google clouds goals
you know what was the whole point what
was their stated mission in adopting the
Google cloud so they have these pillars
that they talk about in Kroger digital
where they want their digital entities
to be available accessible and relevant
to their customers and that equals a
better customer experience and they also
wanted an accelerated transformation so
that's where the Google cloud
professional services team and our
partner network came into play where we
could send teams of people side by side
with Kroger engineers and help them not
only through their migration itself but
to plan out all of those technical
attributes that need to be decided to do
any large-scale cloud migration and then
finally the the key thing that Kroger
wanted to do with Google cloud was to be
their innovation partner so the buzzword
obviously a IML and what that really
boils down to is to better understanding
their customers and the interesting
thing that Kroger found is that the more
relevant they made their digital
experience for their customers
counterintuitive thing happened actually
more customers visited their stores and
they spent more time in the stores which
is an incredible outcome for all of you
who also have this on the channel
experience that you're trying to improve
and motivate and build
so the key thing before I pass it over
to Jeff is that if you leave this
conference thinking that cloud is just
VMs and somebody else's data center
you've missed the point
the
opportunity to partner with Google cloud
is the opportunity to transform your
business for the next 25 years in retail
and with that I'll pass it over to Jeff
thanks Joe
so I'm Jeff Hecht I'm the engineering
manager for the digital search team
specifically within Kroger this is the
search engine that's used for you know
the website and the mobile app and
things like that so kind of where do you
start
right and so we'll read we're we chose
to start was what what are we currently
using that supports our business what
got us to where we are today but isn't
gonna take us to the next level the Joe
is referring to so I think this diagram
that we have here really describes
things well right we've got you know a
mix of a lot of different technologies
you guys are probably a lot of you guys
are probably using a lot of this
technology yourselves right but we're
doing it all on Prem right and it's it's
it's time to sort of kick it into gear
and take it to the next level right and
so the big question we had was do we do
a lift and shift type thing do we take
our existing search strategy that we're
doing do we move that out there and you
know realize the benefits of GCP in that
way or is this something that we can do
to completely reap LAT form the search
you know solution that we have which is
what ultimately what we chose to do so
as we got into this we you know it's
kind of overwhelming right it's like
okay cool we're gonna go to the cloud
all right cool how do we get there what
do we do so you know we had three
different options right the first option
is do we do it all ourselves right you
know that's that's a tall tall task
especially when you know we have limited
experience in GCP on our staff right and
we still have to keep the old thing
running so you know that's these are all
real business problems that we have
right so the next thing right is - okay
so should we just basically partner with
Google right and utilize their you know
utilize their professional services
teams the Technical Account managers and
the consultants to make this happen now
they've got loads of experience and we
can probably get there quickly but
ultimately what we want is we want to
have that center of excellence
in our teams right and so that's where
we chose ultimately kind of option three
that you see up on the screen there
which is we kind of did a hybrid right
so we have our team working with Google
and one of the Google partners preferred
partners we we used spring ml in this
case and you know basically we had
spring ml and Google resources you know
literally shoulder-to-shoulder pairing
at workstations building you know the
software to fun you know it was
software-defined architecture and things
that we built here to to make all this
happen and in the at the you know in the
end we ended up not only producing a you
know a really awesome solution for this
but we also have people who are invested
in it and understand how it works right
so the way we got we the way we kind of
arrived at this as we we got everybody
in a room a big room three days I think
and we had several Kroger engineers
several Google folks several spring ml
folks and we started with okay what what
is the thing that we have today and what
do what is you know where do we want to
take this right and so we got all of our
tribal knowledge all this stuff that you
know that that's the intangibles right
we tried to drug all that out and and
everything we wanted it to be in
essentially coming out of that we ended
up with this what I call a reference
architecture if not only for search but
for a lot of the other applications that
we're moving out to the cloud as well
and one of the big founding tenants that
we had as everything infrastructure is
code everything infrastructure as code
nothing no console stuff right we want
to be able to to be able to spin these
things up tear it down iterate iterate
iterate so that was that was huge for us
so you know there again the other point
that you see there with building and
adapt and move on is the infrastructure
as code pieces were really valuable for
us to be able to do this right and you
know we're never we're never building
something that we can't build again and
again and again
right
we failed a lot right so don't be afraid
to fail this is you know I'll raise my
hand and say you know the the the
biggest lessons I've ever had in life
are the ones where I did something wrong
you know and you know you know fixing it
by doing it over and over and over and
then you guys have all seen the pets
versus livestock thing this is this is
truly a huge huge tenant in moving your
applications out there you've got to get
away from having these special-purpose
things oh this this host you know this
it does this thing right you got to get
away for that and so when the guys would
come up to me they would say hey this is
really great we got the new thing
working right and I'd say that's really
awesome guys I'm really glad for you
tear it down and do it again and do it
again and do it again and so and the
team was the team was fantastic they did
it they did a great job with that so as
we as we did this right we started to
see our mindset change we went from this
on-prem pets sort of you know mentality
right to one where we're expecting
transient resources and things like that
and being able to being able to move
workloads around very easily some of the
other things that we kind of struggled
with more as a global Kroger we is
things like data classification what's
safe you know what what are things we
feel comfortable moving out to the cloud
this is our first thing right what are
things that we feel comfortable moving
in the cloud search was obviously a you
know a pretty easy decision to make
because all that stuff's available on
the Internet today right so there's
there's not a whole lot we're gonna be
throwing out there that you know
everybody who's crawling us doesn't
already have right and then and then
also being able to trust and empower our
engineers to do things that maybe they
haven't done before right if you think
about on-prem right you've got a team of
guys they're standing up VMs you have
people installing the OS and doing that
kind of thing right where this is
different right we've got you know
kubernetes and we've got these docker
ice containers of things and you know
we're we are really embracing the you
know the DevOps on both both sides of
that right I mean development and
operations our team has as you know
really done a great job supporting both
of those so it's not all unicorns and
rainbows though
we had quite a few speed bumps
networking getting network you know
networks installed into into our own
Prem data centers and things like that
was was was sometimes a bit of a
challenge and in fact I think I think
one of one of our data centers we didn't
even have the right kind of fibre line
and so we had to run a fiber line or
something out there it's all these
things that you don't think about right
when you're building when you go oh yeah
we're gonna we're gonna move an
application out there and then you've
got to think what does this actually
mean we're gonna put customers on this
stuff what do we have to have right and
these are all these intangibles that you
got to think about as you start moving
your applications out there right it's
kind of a big deal some simple things
like even our CI CD pipelines right on
our own Prem solution you know we're
deploying our containers in a Bluegreen
fashion and it's something we don't even
think about its in-house tooling okay we
go to we go to GCP and we're you know
we're deploying our applications to our
kubernetes clusters and okay Wow how are
we gonna do Bluegreen deployment because
this is expected for for what we have so
this is also kind of things that sort of
snuck up on us you know as we moved
along and then you know and I could I
could just kind of keep going and going
and going on that thing you know the
important thing is here is when you're
doing your discovery phase think about
the stuff that you take for granted when
you're trying to plan the stuff out and
put your timelines together right so
given that I'm gonna pass the mic over
here to Tony D Loretto he is a cloud
consultant from Google and we work very
closely with Tony and his team to to
make all this stuff happen thanks Jeff
so yes as Jeff said my name is Tony
Loretto I was the cloud consultant
working with Jeff's team to help the
migration and all the architecture I
want to walk you through now just how we
thought about building out this new
system on GCP right but before we could
even move the first byte we had to have
a plan in place like we talked about and
you know we wanted to make sure that we
would cover all the bases and we had
everything in the cloud ready to go so
to do so I wanted to focus on five key
points and I you know
they all begin with an S icon the 5 s is
simplification right you'll see in a
second what we went from to what we
ended up with security making sure
making sure it was secure in the cloud
stability being able to grow in scale
with our customer base
Kroger being a national company has
customers all over the United States and
in the world coming to the website so we
wanted to make sure we could grow with
that data science or the science bit and
finally micro services right all of
these different pieces what we had to
incorporate into the architecture to
make sure that this application could
grow with Kroger and its customers needs
so as we already saw this is what I
walked into and again probably not too
similar to what many other people here
are using today right we have sort of
this the search franken stack if you
will with a lot of different platforms
where the teams had to manage all the
different releases and patches and
security and platforms and you know
making sure that that all the
infrastructure was set up for it in
ports you can you know the list goes on
and on this is obviously one of the true
benefits of migrating to the cloud is
not having to deal with all of that but
you know this is where we started with
this was our you know beginning point of
the roadmap and there were a lot of
different areas of which we had to
ensure that we incorporated into this
architecture not only just the platforms
themselves and the technology but
testing and validation rolling out being
able to make sure there were no single
points of failure and all the while
ensuring that the data was at the right
place at the right time so like I said
the first thing we focused on was the
simplification of this architecture we
wanted to go from this multi tenant
multi platform stack into something
straight forward and as you know
probably with any application there are
a few key elements or key phases to the
architecture that needs to include so
this is the initial sort of look at what
we had to migrate to incorporating those
key tenants the ingestion of data coming
in from Kroger the transformation of the
data how are we going to prepare it for
being used storage in some vehicle
within Google Cloud and then like Jeff
mentioned running on kubernetes or the
application
lair of which all the customers could
then interact with again this is a very
solid baseline template for almost any
application running in the cloud because
it does incorporate many of those key
tenants of a pipeline or of an
application running in the cloud one of
the best things that Google has the
advantages to come in and just drop in
and replace some of the existing
infrastructure we are able to identify
in that previous architecture which of
these elements lined up to the different
hexagons and the different verticals you
see in here doing so allowed us to
iterate fast sometimes fail fast but
iterate rapidly and to continue to move
on the next thing we focused on was
stability again I wanted to make sure
that we had the ability to grow and
handle traffic as Kroger grew as you saw
at the very beginning Kroger has been
and we wanted to be able to capture all
of that and to deliver those low latency
and you know high durability stability
requirements so we could have easily
have just taken that initial
architecture and just copy it into three
zones and been done with it but anybody
who's been using any sort of cloud
service or managed service in the past
knows that this isn't the optimal way of
doing so we're Google really shines
again is having those managed services
that scale with customers where you
don't have to worry about bringing up at
your own in the instances of them for
things such as pub/sub at the very
beginning or a data flow so what we were
able to do is you know we iterated on
this but having in multiple regions
allowed that layer to be able to grow
and scale and handle customers wherever
they were the next thing we want to do
is focus on scaling this out so we took
that architecture that we just looked at
and we sort of condensed it down to what
we really wanted to focus on really what
is Kroger's IP and what they should be
bringing in and that's really in that
application layer right all the other
hexagons to the left that's Google
managed services that we've built and
tried and trued and tested so let's
really focus on what makes the kroger
search application
unique so what we were able to do is
focus on deploying applications in a
rolling manner into the each of the
different regions within Google
container burn areas engine once we're
able to do that initially through a test
we want to focus more on the service
aspect that
oriented architecture that you always
hear about so we're able to break it up
into multiple apps and every app could
then do what it was made for imagine
moving a giant monolith to a more nimble
and service focused application itself
this pattern is very simple to then grow
within scale and as you could see once
you have one app down you can easily
replicate it to many others this
architecture that you end up seeing is
not dissimilar from what we ended up
pushing forward and again it is a tried
and true pattern that you can then use
for any of your applications kubernetes
allowed us to scale and it allowed us to
be able to really focus on what Kroeger
needed to do the next thing we had to
focus on with security obviously
security is very important to everybody
that's using Google cloud so some of the
key considerations that we thought about
when building out this first initial
architecture of using Google managed
services are number one if you can use
Google managed services it takes the
responsibility away from having a single
point or single person worrying about
managing different instances the next
thing we're service accounts as well
service accounts were deployed
throughout and again it's one of our
best practices by enabling extensive
logging and monitoring we're able to get
at any issues immediately to be able to
detect and to be able to optimize around
finally key management making sure that
all the data that was going through was
secure at rest and in transit and
finally we also used manage node pools
to be able to ensure that we had enough
architecture or enough infrastructure
when we needed it and finally the last
thing we focused on was the science
aspect right everybody again wants to
get to the AI the ml but after we're
able to build out this architecture then
we can really dive into that so some of
the different areas that are
opportunities for doing data science
with an architecture one was real-time
ingestion or streaming analytics so when
the data was coming in do we see any
issues with that second was data quality
analytics once we're doing our
transformation on the data do we notice
that any of our providers are upstream
sources had issues or you know was
delivering at the wrong time that we
needed to correct
third was any sorts of prescriptive or
predictive analytics on top of the data
once it was in storage being able to do
modeling and be able to get at really
what our customers data is key and then
finally the usage our customer analytics
on the app itself where are they
interacting with the app what are their
points of confusion or areas that we can
then improve for the next iteration and
with that I'm gonna turn it back over to
Jeff to talk a little about lessons
learned and the next steps yeah so
lessons learned I don't think I have
enough time to go through all the
lessons learned right but some of the
important takeaways right it's important
to understand that you know my focus and
my team's focus is primarily on search
and relevance and things like that and
one of the important things that we're
doing is here we're doing actual data
science now to let our customers actions
on our site talk to us about what types
of products we should be returning based
on those types of search terms and you
know and that's that's that a IML thing
that that Tony was talking about there
you know and that's real big you know
for us with what we're doing in some
data proc stuff that we have set up
internally we have a system called
Agatha and so we're actually doing real
data science on this too to be able to
do this this type of stuff the other
thing that's great is we're able to
launch completely new stacks fully
populate them with with with content and
everything literally with the click of a
button one of the one of the guys in my
team Jim literally on Saturday spun up a
new environment that we needed for for
some for some testing and the whole
thing took an hour to build the entire
search stack so you know that goes back
to that whole infrastructure is Code
piece it's huge right the other nice
thing and then you can probably saw in
those diagrams that Tony had up there
but is the the scaling factor of this we
literally can scale this thing out to
infinity
you know it's it's it's it's it's really
easy for us to do that now and then you
know the the new search platform and a
lot of this is based on some of the GCP
tools
a lot of this is also based on the Ryoka
texture that we did of the search engine
but we can handle you know orders of
magnitude more volume that we did before
with just an amazing improvement in in
response time and stuff so you know it's
the whole RER Kotecha and then dropping
it on GCP was was just a absolute
benefit to us so right what does this
mean then for the future of Kroger on
the cloud there's a ton of work to do
here right
lots of work loads to go more than I can
talk about here some of those
potentially lift and shift some of those
really texture type things but the
important thing to take away from this
is that our application really broke
down a lot of barriers for the teams
that are sort of riding in our coattails
and following along so you know that
helps to accelerate the rest of those
that those applications and those teams
which is super important for Kroger and
ultimately our customers you know to be
able to take you know to take that to
the next level and then the other nice
thing that's about it you know that
working with the with the Google guys
and is you know if I could put this in
one sentence I think it was how can I
help you help Kroger right I can't tell
you how many times Tony would give me a
call and say hey I've got these guys
from BQ you know from bigquery and they
want to understand what's important to
you for how you're doing your your
machine learning and your AI and things
like that we'd hop on a phone call and
you know I have these discussions and
that's the first time that I've ever had
you know a partner get with me and say I
want to make your job easier what can I
do to do this it's usually me you know
saying hey this thing that you that you
you know that we're trying to use
doesn't work or I needed to I need to
pound the square peg to this round hole
and so you know that's that's been
that's been fantastic I've really really
enjoyed that too and it's it's kind of
cool to also think that you know things
that are important to us as Kroger might
actually be influencing you know
products and things that Google's gonna
you know develop someday that might be
you know beneficial to you guys as well
so you know that's that's pretty great
yeah that's
that's pretty cool
[Music]